we're gonna do a little summary of all
the exciting things that have happened
here in JavaScript in the year 2012 I
know it's been a big year for everyone
personally uh-huh and you know I have
some personal news I decided to go comma
first it's kind of a big decision for me
but thanks to your support what do you
what do you mean this is so exciting
hi everybody good to see you again Wow I
had no I mean Thomas but semicolons I
mean I know it's a really big issue uh
you sound sorry yeah you sound kind of
just like fat you know I can't believe
you just call me fat no no that he's the
guy who designed the Twitter bootstrap
yeah he had something with that
Crockford on there anyway I'm doing
about it the thing is I actually if you
hate semicolons I have the perfect thing
for you yeah yeah perfect thing for for
semicolon haters it'll solve all of your
problems there's one catch but
HTML had Hamill and CSS hats s but
jeaious had just yes that
now CoffeeScript has brothers at ur
style of its own but there's just one
little problem when and every stroke a
it's enough to make mistake with
JavaScript source maps land-uses really
yeah
kind of awesome you should really check
it out but I already know CoffeeScript
you know you already know yeah I did not
I didn't know what do you use it to use
it for your your own development I do
but all the good names were taking but I
think what did you so you you wrote like
a templating library let me guess yeah
there's like a thousand of those I know
so how did you I mean how did you find a
name for that I don't even know I mean
there's like all the namespaces just
completely saturated well Dustin here
helped me come up with what it's really
good I think you're gonna like it it's
super frolic catalystic expialidocious
run it in the browser or the server
using node a yes you can use it in
protective bundles
Wow awesome that is so awesome and so
awesome that you would name a
CoffeeScript library with Jas that is
just the clarity is awesome and I'm kind
of in the market for a temp let me
measure myself because I'm developing
this new new iPhone app Oh objective-c
oh no no no I didn't learn objective-c
yeah you actually don't actually need
technically to learn objective-c yeah no
I had a little something myself I cooked
up if you're shipping iOS and dream of
the box you'll make you think about
going native but X goes the big headache
think of things like foam yeah or
whatever it's called this week it helps
you to solve a web app without any need
to speak Objective C C Objective C
Objective C don't need that crap or get
in the App Store take it from me
help us run the room just make sure he's
sober when you do semester be shipping
when you are skipping Objective C
Wow Foam capsules really useful Thanks
pretty awesome you just the thing is I
mean you think like oh just use PhoneGap
and we'll solve my problems but it's
actually it's kind of actually not that
easy there are a few catches okay yeah
I'll tell you about it right now
if you build Oh besides you can skip ie
you think es5 makes you feel alive so
long day query
too bad gingerbreads
still so damn much red sure it's still
WebKit but it runs like Android 2.3
that it's the new ie6 I don't be heard
yeah it was it really hard to ship yeah
you know it's web apps are just
complicated with JavaScript you have to
send all this JavaScript over the wire
because you know what do you what are
you doing yeah all by myself
that is awesome because I have been hand
humidifying my cousin's like last year
you're welcome yeah yeah it's super
tough but I'll just try to say this gzip
Thanks
it's just there's so much tech out there
and there's like all these new things
and you know you still remember the old
things and I don't know it's just so
overwhelming sometimes seems to kind of
get down but I think there's hope
it's 2012 and still we are Holi filling
xhr where's my client side require it
makes me Oh Jen why the doom and gloom
just look out there in this only thing
can change your tune we all good point
Mandy now I see it is up to you and me
what we want J s to be will make
so angry
and expertise